i'm going to begin by drawing the
diagram this is always useful you can
see in questions one and two they give
you diagram which is nice
in the subsequent questions they often
do not that's actually part of the skill
it's a skill you develop so
look at it read it
and form the correct diagram often okay
so let's give this a go um here's my
drawing roughly
and you've got your
you got a boat over here
and you've got a right angle here 800
meters here now then there's something a
bit different yes there's a dotted line
um this
now what is that dot of light what does
it represent
the nine degrees
there are there are some very small
markings there you can just make them
out there are some arrows like this
which means that those two are parallel
so this is the horizontal okay yes well
done give yourself a pat on the back
okay now
therefore
when they say the next the question says
the angle of depression right so that's
looking
down
that's why they've got it in
here that's 90 degrees okay
now um you've got your
800 meters over here what's the length
we're trying to find what's the question
hi good so it's just like this one isn't
it this is what i'm after
okay now do you remember in this
question what we did is we said okay
height
35 meters this one's opposite and this
one's adjacent
how did we decide that they were
opposite and adjacent
why don't you angles
good from the english point of view i
said look let's stand here and you look
over there and then you look over here
fine
but i've got a problem here see that
angle you've got that nine degrees
it's not in the triangle right so you
can't stand at this angle and say well
what what are these it's not even inside
right it's not in the right spot
so you've got two two different parts
you can take to work this out do you
want to give a suggestion
because i thought since the lines are
parallel don't have the same shapes in
the same angle okay keep going so
what angle did you put inside
okay where did you put it
near the book good good okay so here's
option one
you could say that angle down there at
the boat is nine degrees now by the way
let's we have some languages we learned
this early in the year under geometry
these lines are parallel
and what dynasty said is that these
angles have the same shape but they have
a special name as well as that does
anyone know it starts with an a
alternate yes hold on
you've got alternate angles here can you
recognize that look look you've got the
zebra
yeah yeah so there's there's the nine
degrees oh sorry that's 90.
um there's the nine degrees up there and
there's the z that you've got which is
why there's nine over here
okay does that make sense
okay do you wanna ask me um the second
solution or the second the other way yep
it's like
because it's nine degrees the other side
of that line could be 81 degrees yes
very good okay so method two is to say
look see how you've got diana here and
you've got 90 here right
as well as finding this angle i can also
find out this one these two are they
added to 90 which means they're starts
with a c remember
it's complementary very good so close
country is very close um they're
complementary they add up to 90.
the angle you add to 9 is 81.
okay
so
let's just have a go we can actually do
this with both of them right watch
we'll do it this way first okay um
darcy's way if you've got 90 degrees
over here
which side is this
is it hypotenuse opposite or adjacent
it's opposite it's very good so you go
opposite and that makes this one
adjacent yep
so let's write out like this
right
again it's going to be 10 isn't it right
so tan of
90 degrees equals
equals
height over 800. very good well done
okay and then you rearrange just like
you did before and you'll get a height
which is what's 800 times 10 9 someone
worked it out 126.7075
good so it rounds um whoops sorry it
rounds up just like the other one okay
now just quickly suppose you did it the
other way
yeah okay so what happens right you get
you're working a little different
but we should end up on the same answer
watch um let's get rid of this 9.
i will show you after going through
i'll show you which one i recommend i
wonder if you can spot as we do both
okay so i'm going to get rid of that 9
i'm going to get rid of adjacent
opposite because they're changed now
right
and as nathan suggested
we pop 81 up there
okay
so now which side is which
which one's the opposite one
no 800 it's the 800 because you're
looking all the way over there oh okay
that's opposite
now this one is adjacent
right
okay so now i write a different sentence
it looks like this but not quite
it goes tan off not nine degrees
81 degrees that's the angle we're
looking at now it's opposite on adjacent
800 on height
so this is interesting
it's upside down
because the opposite adjacent flipped
around when you were standing from a
different
point of view okay
so now what do i have to do here um
these two i want them to swap okay so
i'll multiply by the height
and then i'll divide
by
1081
okay stare at this spit for
um a second with me because this it's
the confusing one right the other one is
better ah now we'll talk about why in a
second i agree okay
um 800 over 10 anyone you can chuck any
calculator and sure enough you'll get
126.7
and you get 127 meters to the nearest
meter but i agree but this method's
probably a bit better why
you don't have to switch but why don't
you have to switch why do we have to
switch this time but not this time
because
it's good yeah yeah so
it depends on your point of view right
i want the opposite side to be on top
because that makes this on the top it's
easier to deal with right so i should
pick the angle opposite the height
that's this one over here right so that
makes it a little easier to work with
if you accidentally pick the wrong one
no problems you'll get the right answer
both ways okay but if you can choose
try to make it so what you're trying to
find is on the top on the numerator not
on the denominator it's also faster